ça et nous avons pris notre photo à Istanbul 1
millions à Izmir 700 000 à Ankara
Nous avons donné deux cent mille concerts au total.
des chiffres en millions, quelle terreur est-ce
Melek, qui est également membre de l'organisation
Aider et encourager une organisation terroriste
et la force morale pour rendre tout le peuple
Cette fois, le pouvoir qui s'est rendu compte qu'il était enveloppé
il était sur le point d'interdire, l'essentiel est
ces concerts de commentaires signifient Hope
s'il y a il y a la dimension de résistance ju-wan test
tokacı Gündeş 30 intense Elsa Pelin
tarte Esen symbole bénévole à mon ami
tellement
s'abonner
Aygül fox est membre du Grup Yorum.
Je suis la mère de Selim comme ça, Helin 5 juin
Il est né à Diyarbakir en 1991.
La photo est bébé Helin là-bas, je suis en congé
Je suis venu vers toi j'avais l'habitude d'aller à la cuisine pour manger
J'essaie de le faire mais il n'est pas intéressé
Je le veux et je le prendrais sur mes épaules
qu'as-tu commencé à cuisiner
c'était un enfant quand tu es venu ici avec lui
Il aimait s'asseoir ensemble et regarder.
le coucher de soleil est si beau que le soleil se couche
assis ici sur la balançoire que vous deux
ensemble comme ça
Nous avions l'habitude de regarder le soleil se coucher dans ce détroit
écoute du métal directement des navires qui vont
dit qu'il aimait un peu les noirs dans son âme
complot rebelle parfois je disais ça trop
Cette musique n'est-elle pas forte mais sa mère
Chanson folklorique Art Music par âge
Tu écoutes ça dit que c'est comme ça sur mille
Il s'excite ou dit que j'écoute ça aussi
Musique pour une âme un peu rebelle
Je pense toujours quand je suis au collège
Le frère de Selma Fırat du Grup Yorum
étudié ensemble dans la même université.
ami Grup Yorum est cette connaissance comme ça
En 2014, les gens d'un processus qui a commencé
Je dis viens bro, c'est déjà dans le même processus
Nous sommes devenus les commentateurs de l'équipe de commentaires actuelle.
beaucoup d'entre eux se battent dans Helin's Actually
compagnons, compagnons du même processus
nous, les humains, avons commencé ce petit petit étudiant
les actions sont plus fortes que nous sommes plus forts
super bien sûr
actions auxquelles il a participé
ce sont les retenues
le nez a toujours été à l'ordre du jour
Il en a toujours été ainsi depuis le jour de notre création.
pour faire entendre la voix de ton béguin
tous les pouvoirs pour faire des chansons folkloriques
7A à la cible
PES 2015 Oui ça se débloque à partir de 2015
puis cet endroit a été pillé plusieurs fois
Nos instruments sont brisés
tous les membres du commentaire ont été arrêtés
et détention après 10 jours d'iOS 6
Arrêté et SLA resté à Silivri
Voici le cas qui nous était revenu à l'esprit en 2015
Affaire de gestion d'organisation terroriste Hani
Quand on regarde ça, au moins 15 ans, mais dans ce métier
Match Beka qui peut durer jusqu'à 25 ans
était de détruire le commentaire cette fois c'est réel
Dans un sens, les filles de l'AKP font ça sur la tête.
Il l'a mis dans le souffle original tu sais Elif
[Musique]
en ce moment mais nous sommes bons pour faire quelque chose
nous essayons nous essayons nous sommes bons aujourd'hui mais
ça ne veut pas dire
signifie que nous serons dans la même situation
ça ne vient pas
c'est ici les membres du Grup Yorum elin börek
jeûne de la mort pour chanter leurs chansons
C'est là que nous avons mis leur résistance
Telin Borek Island je dis ceci je
compagnon et infirmière j'allais bien maintenant et
C'est quelque chose comme ça qui se termine devant le processus
les maux du corps au jour le jour
augmentant naturellement trop les douleurs
toute ta résistance augmente
le train que quelque chose est arrivé à ta main
en particulier les nerfs dans les nerfs du pied
détruit et ses pieds enflent avant
ça a commencé
c'est marcher parce que mes pieds sont enflés
je me bats mais je me sens bien
Je sors quand je sens
Je marche dans les rues de ce quartier
je vais aussi visiter
a commencé sa main
C'était juste un mois normal de vomissements
C'est une gorgée d'eau et deux gorgées
vomir malgré tout ça, heline
il a toujours fait du mieux qu'il pouvait
s'est forcé en 213 jours de mon amour
grève de la faim indéfinie dans ma main
Je crée, nous ne nous détournerons pas de notre chemin Justice
à contrecœur se battre pour la glace
continuez à marcher ici en payant le prix
tant que nous sommes invincibles et grands
une partie de la main fait une grève de la faim
a commencé à peser 74 kilos
c'est couvert
il est tombé à ce poids, les gens tout à coup
expressions faciales choquées à la vue
Perturbant la grève de la faim qui a duré
le résultat s'est ouvert pour le violet avec grève de la faim
différence entre le jeûne de la mort
il s'avère que votre soratan s'est épuisé
il est 11-15
celui-ci s'est tourné jusqu'au coffre à côté de nous
moi aussi j'ai perdu la main
contrôlons notre musique de feu
Parce que la licence de taureau appartient au chef tonkou
En fait
130 kg de portion de Rezan
Feriköy sur son nouveau testament
Il allait l'emmener au cimetière, mais le dernier
Okmeydanı n'a pas répondu à leur demande
il était sous la direction d'un grand avocat ce jour-là
s'abonner
Cimetière où il a été enterré
essayant d'atteindre le cadavre
gaz aux personnes essayant d'entrer dans le cimetière
attaques avec des bombes, avec des canons à eau
il y a des attaques Helin est mort le jeûne de la mort
premier artiste
cette direction pour pouvoir donner des concerts de sifflet
pour chanter tes chansons
s'abonner